عراقيون غاضبون ويتهمون مليشيا الحشد
بمحاوله اختطاف انجاز وطني والاطباء
النفسيين في قفص الاتهام دراسه لجامعه
كينج تتهمهم بازدواجيه المعايير ورؤوس
حيوانات مفترسه في اسبوع باريس للموضه
تشغل العالم اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
توج المنتخب العراقي للمره الرابعه في
تاريخه بلقب بطل كاس الخليج بنسخته ال 25
يوم الخميس بفوز المنتخب العراقي على
نظيره العماني وعامه الفرحه بالفوز كل
الارجاء العراق كونوا من 35 عام ما قدر
يحصل الفريق اسود الرافدين على اللقب ولكن
الفرحه بالفوز تحولت من احتفالات الى
انتقادات وجدل على المنصات من بعد تنظيم
الحشد الشعبي لحفل التكريم المنتخب او حفل
تكريم المنتخب واللي صار في الحفله كمان
والعرفان قليله بحقكم يا اسود الرافدين
[موسيقى]
شكرا شكرا من اعماق القلوب شكرا بحجم
الفرح والمسرات
[موسيقى]
شكرا من اعماق القلوب شكرا بحجم الفرح
والمسرات
عراقيون يعني استفزهم جدا انه ميليشيا
الحشد الشعبي بتقرر تكرم المنتخب واعتبروا
انه يعني من فين لفين يقرروا يكرم المنتخب
وبصفتهم ايش يعني ولزاد الطين بلغ شعره
للدنيا اكثر هو رفع حارس مرمى المنتخب
جلال حسن لصوره ابو مهدي المهندس النائب
السابق لرئيس الحشد الشعبي واللي انقتل في
غاره جويه قرب مطار بغداد في 2020 وهو
برفقه قائد فيلق القدس التابع للحرس
الثوري الايراني
الحفل كله محاوله من الحشد الاختطاف انجاز
وطني وحساب هذا الانجاز لنفسه وانتقدوا
رفع الصور المهندس بدل من رفع الكاس وعلم
العراق عراقي كمان غضبوا من لاعبين
المنتخب وخصوصا حارس المرمى اللي اعتبر
انه بايدوشيات مسلحه مدعومه من ايران
واعتبروا انه اللاعبين والادارهم لايران
بدل ما يكون للعراق وانهم كده ما بيمثل
الوطن الشريحه واحده
وينضم الينا دكتور باسل حسين الباحث
السياسي العراقي اهلا فيك معانا دكتور
باسل يعني حضرتك زينا تفرجت على هذا
المقطع وهذا الاحتفال ايش رايك فيه
هناك محاوله من قبل
العام
ومن ضمن هذا الفضاء العام حقيقه الجوانب
رياضيه اقتصاديه سياسيه وتاتي محاوله
توظيف هذا
الانتصار العراقي اللي همم علاقه فرحه
عراقيه همم ايضا كانت هناك خيبه ايرانيه
همم او سواء من ايران او من وكلاء ايران
نتذكر الاعتراض الايراني على تسميه الخليج
العربي على كاس الخليج العربي
الاستقبال الحافل الفرق العربيه خلينا
نتذكر جيده انه حافله المنتخب السعودي
يتوقفت له 45 دقيقه
يعني الحفاوه الكبيره للجمهور العراقي
الحافله سعود الفريق السعودي
الباقي الفرق العربيه هذا اغضب الايرانيين
لانه كان ما
15 يوم اسقطت ما عملت عليه ايران طوال 20
سنه بعد انه عملت محاوله فصل العراق عن
البيئه العربيه لكن على حين غير وجد
الايرانيه انفسهم ان هنالك يعني
يعني حب
جارفه الاستقبال الحفاوه بالعرب والعوده
والاشتياق
وكلهم يقولون نحن نشتاق الى العرب الى اخر
هذه بالتاكيد كان عامل ازعاج سواء ايران
محاوله
يعني الاستعاده ما تم خسارته في اثناء
البطوله
يعني ردود الافعال اللي صدرت من الجمهور
العراقي هذا تاكيد يعني واضح ضمن السياق
العام على رفض هذا يعني التدخل ايران او
بالنسبه
لي هي يعني اعتقد نتيجه طبيعيه محاوله
توظيف في السياسه واست ما خسرته ايران
وكلاء ايران ومثل ما قلت كانت فتره 15 يوم
فتره تحديد واضحه لعمق العلاقه العربيه
الدكتور باسل بس خلينا نتكلم كمان على
الغضب الموجه
للمنتخب ولاعبين المنتخب وتحديدا كمان
بزياده حارس
المرمى هل انت بتشوف انهم يعني همم تم
توريطهم في هذا الموضوع ولا انه لا يجب
القاء اللوم عليهم ايضا لمشاركتهم في هذا
الاحتفال
لا نعتقد انه اللاعبين مغلوب على يعني
امرهم يعني حقيقه وايضا هناك يعني الادراك
المستوى الثقافي يعني كثير من الامور اللي
داخلت لان انتم عارفين
يعمل في داخل العراق يعني
يضع فيه جانبه رهانات حتى يعني الخوف حتى
من استبعاد المنتخب لانه هناك ربما يمكن
حتى يتم محاربته استبعتهم المنتخب
وبالتالي يعني اعتقد انه هذا جزء يعني من
هذا البيئه العراقيه المعقده
لموازنه الحسابات وبالتاكيد يعني اللاعبين
العراقيين اللاعبين وطنيين شعارنا حبهم
لهذا الوطن
عراقي تحديدا في كل المعافي يعني اعتقد
انه ربما حادثه
خطا من قبل اللاعبين لكن اللاعبين لا يمكن
حقيقه يعني يعني بس هم في هذه المجال
همم ميديا كاتبين كمان كانوا بيتكلموا انه
في وسط كل الاحتفاء بالبطوله والاشياء
اللي صارت واو واو واو جاء هذا المشهد
وانه هذا المشهد هيخرب كيف كان المش-
العالم بيشاهد العراق خلال هذه الايام ايش
رايك في هذا الموضوع انه منظر هذا
الاحتفال وحمل صوره ابو مهدي المهندس
بالنسبه لبقيه العالم الخارجي
قلت هو عمليه
توظيف سياسي همم من قبل الحشد لها
اللاعبين واللاعبين
تمزجهم في هذه همم هناك صراع سياسي حقيقه
همم حول فوز المنتخب كثير من الزيارات في
الاخرين حتى يعني نزلت قلت اني يعني حقيقه
مقهوره على المدرب بالاجنبي اللي ما يعرف
يعني همم من هو هؤلاء ربما حتى ولماذا هم
يعني يتم زيارتهم الى اخره يعني هذا حتى
خارج نطاق يعني
اكثر مقهور عليه مدرب الاجنبي الذي زوجها
بدون صراعات سياسيه ربما هذا الزيارات
متعبه على النحو يعني مضحك حقيقي
دكتور باسل حسين الباحث السياسي العراقي
شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
اهلا من جديد في دراسه ان عملت في جامعه
كامبرد العريقه حاطه الاطباء النفسيين تحت
المجهر وفي قفص الاتهام الدراسه مع ان من
سنه 2018 لكن مثلها مثلك كثير اشياء هذه
الايام على السوشيال ميديا فجاه رجعت تم
تداولها وفاتحه نقاش كبيره الدراسه ايش
بتقول بتقول انه الدكاتره النفسيين عندهم
ازدواجيه في المعايير في اختيار العلاج
الامثل لما بيكونوا بيفكروا فيه مرضاهم
مقارنه بلمن يكون الامر متعلق فيهم هم
نفسهم كيف يعني هذول الباحثين اللي شملوهم
بالدراسه كانوا او اخذوا بعين او اخذوا
عينه 515 طبيب نفسي انه الطبيب النفسي في
معظم الحالات لو بفكر في علاج لنفسه
بيختار دائما العلاج الاخفاء فمثلا في
الامراض مثل الاكتئاب الاطباء النفسيين ما
بيكتبوا لنفسهم دواء وبيفضلوا العلاج
بالمراقبه الحديثه ولو موضوع متعلق بامراض
مثل الفصام او غيره فبيفضل الدواء على انه
يتم حجزهم او فرض قيود معينه عليهم يعني
الواحد عاد الواحد طبعا يعني عاده لما
يحتار في العلاج مع اي طبيب بيقول لي
الدكتور يا دكتور لو انت مكاني ايش بتسوي
لكن يبدو بحسب هذه الدراسه انه الاطباء
النفسيين لما الانسان لهذا السؤال ما
بيقول الجواب الصحيح الحق اما الاسباب
مجهوله بس من الناس عن من الصاج جلسه طبعا
بتحلل وبتاخذ وبتدي فاحنا قلنا خلينا
نفترض حسن النيه ونسمع منهن بنفسهم فاهمني
من عمان الطبيب النفسي محمد زهران اهلا
فيك معنا همم
خليني اول شيء ابتدي اسالك عن رايك الشخصي
في هذه الدراسه
يعني شوفي انا عشان يعني كبدايه بدي احكي
لك دليل العلمي طبيا لا يعتمد على دراسه
واحده اضعف دليل علمي اضعف دليل علمي هو
الدليل وراء الشخص اللي تروح على دكتور
يقول لك والله انا حسبته هذا اضعف دليل
علمي لكن اقوى دليل علمي اسمه ميته انا
لست اللي هو مجموعه عديده من الدراسات
التي
تمت بحيث انها تعتمد نتيجه معينه لا شيء
حيث انه يطلع كلكم منديشن بالنهايه نقدر
احنا كاطباء ناخذ ونحكي للاخرين للناس
يعني
2018 حقيقه انتشرت في في مجال علميه ولكن
دراسه من ال 2010 كانت معموله يعني عمله
قديمه هي دراسه واحده وتم طرح السؤال فعلا
على عدد من الاطباء لكن هذا لا
يثبت بانه بان هذا يعني هاي النتيجه 100
بالميه لو انت طرحت على على الاطباء هاي
هاي الاسئله نفسها في الوقت الحالي ممكن
يجاوبه ليش ليش اه ليش انت بتقول لي يعني
انه انت رافض لهذا التعميم اللي جايب فيه
هذه الدراسه وانه العين يعني صغيره
في نقد في بعض
الدراسه طيب
اصلا انت لا يجوز ان تعالج نفسك انت طبيب
نفسي لا يجوز ان تعالج نفسي
اذا اي طبيب نفسي
كيف انتم تسالوا الاطباء نفسيين انه انت
لو
مرضت». هو نسبه الامراض الموجوده عند ناس
تنطبق على نسبه الامر نسبه الامراض موجوده
عند الاطباء نفسه وعند الاطباء العامين
عند اي طبيب فهو بشري زيه زي الناس
لو بتطرح عليهم الخيار فبيختاروا خيارات
غير اللي بيعطوها للناس وخليني اقول لك
حاجه ليش الان كمان هذه الدراسه لاقيه صده
كبير عند الناس يعني لانه كمان الان صار
في اتهامات للاطباء النفسيين بالافراط في
توزيع
الحبوب او الادويه اللي هي مضاده للاكتئاب
وما همم الى ذلك لكل احد يروح لهم كل ما
احد يروح لهم مجلس عندهم شويه يصرفه له
دواء ضد الاكتئاب كيف بترد على هذا
الموضوع
دعاء يعني حقيقه احنا بنعتمد على الدليل
العلمي هلا سابقا يمكن ما كان في
الجايد لاين علمي
في الدراسه
[موسيقى]
بحكي انه احنا لازم نعطي ابر لمرضى الذهون
اللي انكسكه لكن بعد ال 2010 صار في
توصيات انه تقرير الانتكاسات في دليل علمي
قوي طلع ميته انا لسه زي ما حكيت في
البدايه هو اقوى دليل العلمي انه
الانتكاسات تعالج في الابر فهم من طرحوا
السؤال هذا على الاطباء اللي هم جاوبوا
انه انا ما بفضل الابر على نفسي بس ما كان
هذا الدليل العلمي اصلا طالع في وقت
بالنسبه لموضوع السؤال الاخر انهم السؤال
الثاني كان على الاكتئاب انه لو انت همم
يعني اجاك مريض هل انت بتنصح انه ياخذ
مضاد اكتئاب ولا انه يستنى
هذا السؤال على المرضى امي بشكل عام
جاوبوا انه انه ينعطى مضاد للاكتئاب لكن
هذا الشيء في الوقت الحالي همم
جنب القائد فحسب درجه الاكتئاب بنحكي يعني
في رجال خفيفه من الاكتئاب ممكن ان تعالج
بالثرب والعلاج الكلامي العلاج المعرفي
السلوكي برده بحكي ميته انا لسه ال ال
المتوسط ممكن ان يعالج بالايذر يعني يا
اما ثوره يعني في اتجاه عالمي لصرف
الادويه
وكلاهما معا افضل شيء يعني انه كلاهما
افضل شيء لكن كل ما اشد حده الاكتئاب كل
ما كانت دواء له يعني له فعاليه اكبر
فعاليه
فهذا الدليل العلمي هذا كله الحديث نحكي
ممكن يجاوبوا اجوبه مختلفه لكن بردا بحكي
النقد انه اصلا انت ما بصير تسال اطباء
انه يعني بصير ليش الطبيب نفسي يعالج نفسه
يعني
شكرا على هذه المعلومات
الطبيب النفسي محمد زهران شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
في السودان في اخبار متداوله بتتكلم عن
شغلانه اول مره بنسمع فيها متعهد بيع
كراسي متحركه الي المتسولين
بالضبط هي هذه الوظيفه فعلا الاخبار بتقول
كانت انه في منطقه في العاصمه اسمها تقاطع
الشعب وفيها متسولين كثار في الشوارع وعلى
الاشارات وامام المحلات هناك في شخص باجر
كراسي متحركه للمتسولين يسهل عليهم عملهم
وانهم يحزنوا الناس على حالهم وبحسب
المتداول في الايجار للكرسي الواحد هو
1000 جنيه سوداني في اليوم يعني دولار ونص
او اكثر شويه في تفاعلكم احنا حبينا نتاكد
من الانباء وارسلنا كاميرا
بتتكلم عنها وهذا ما وجدنا
مثل ما شفت فعليا في متسولين كثار ومنهم
عدد لا باس فيه على كراسي متحركه بعضهم
واضح انه عنده اطراف مبتوره لكن في اخرين
ما يمكن يعني الجزم او التاكد من اصابتهم
من عدمها عموما الموضوع اثار استغراب
كثيرين وهو بصراحه يعني مستوى جديد من
استغلال الظروف الصعبه اللي اصلا سبب في
زياده نسبه التسول يعني في السودان ما في
ارقام رسميه لكن مصادر اكدت لنا انه في
الخرطوم بس في اكثر من 11000 متسول للاسف
[موسيقى]
اسباب عريس للموضه حدث عالمي بلفت انظار
العالم كله كل سنه خصوصا المهتمين بهذا
العالم وامسكن في افتتاحه الاسبوع
الفساتين اللي ظهروا فيها عارضات ازياء
واللي كانت مزينه برؤوس حيوانات مفترسه
بتصميمات عليها رؤوس فهد واسد والذئب
كمان كانت من الحضور ولفته الانظار
بالفستان مزين براس اسد
[موسيقى]
التصاميم هذه سرعان ما قسمت العالم بين
ناس اعجبها والناس لا لكنها كمان كانت سبب
انقسام من نوع مختلف وخاصه في عالم
المدافعين عن حقوق الحيوان فمنظمه بدء
الشهيره المدافع عن حقوق الحيوان نددت
باستخدام دار الازياء لرؤوس حيوانات بحجم
طبيعي في تصاميمها ولو انها رؤوس مزيفه
وقالت انه هذه التصاميم بتمجد الصيد
للترفيه كمان استنكرت استخدام الحرير
والصوف في التصاميم وقالت انه في ديدان
قذف بتقتل حيه من اجلها وخرفان بيتم
استغلاللها دار الازياء كانت سبقت هذه
الهجوم واعلنت في بيان انه ما في اي حيوان
تعرض للاذى خلال تصميم للمجموعه ومن
الرؤوس صناعيه لكن هذا ايضا ردت عليه
الفتاه واعتبرته تصريح كاذب
كمان عبر انستغرام على الانتقادات
المواجهه ضدها وعبر بالفستان واكد انه راس
الاسد اللي زي الفستانها من صنع الانسان
من مواد صناعيه ومحقيقي ابدا لكن مو كثير
ذروها خاصه انه الاحد تاريخ مع منظمات
حقوق الحيوان ومن سنتين كانت عرضه لهجوم
من قبلهم من بعد ما لقتوها طالعه من متجر
همم يعني بيبيع فرو حقيقي من الحيوانات
فيعني لو حطينا الحيوانات وجد الحبوب على
جنب في اطلاله ثانيه يعني مشاهدينا بتفوز
عاده كده بالمرتاح يعني بلقب الاغرب في
عرض امس وهي اطلاله مغنيه الراب الامريكيه
دوجات واللي ما كان حتى
لاصابع رجليها ومغطيتها الافقطع الكريستال
[موسيقى]
طيب انا احب ان اوريكم اشياء غريبه ما
بقعد اشوف الاشياء هذه لوحدي وانفجر طيب
المشاهدين احنا وصلنا الى ختام حلقه اليوم
انا اعود والقاكم غدا ان شاء الله في حلقه
جديده من تفاعلكم في امان الله مشاهدينا
[موسيقى]